it is 6 44 and on the 8th of every month
we want you to call your buddy and
remind them to do their breast self exam
denise valdez has today's buddy check 8
report
with so much going on in the world it
might be easy to forget to take care of
yourself
but monthly self exams and annual
mammograms
are the best way to stay connected to
your body and notice any kind of changes
with over 25 years of experience dr
terry quinn mclaughlin is an
accomplished
breast cancer surgeon committed to
making sure that her patients get the
care they need
especially during a global outbreak are
you running into women who maybe feel a
little
a little lonely feel a little isolated
well yes we are running into that
because this is the code
generation and we're all feeling lonely
and isolated
and then if you add a layer of a new
diagnosis of breast cancer
that might just be on the straw that
breaks the camel's back so to speak
but if caught early breast cancer is
very survivable
dr mclaughlin stresses when it's time
for your mammogram
go somewhere that does a lot of them
just be sure that you go to a
high volume place a place that does a
good number of mammogram screening
whether it's digital um traditional 2d
or the 3d the who is reading them
and the skill of the mammographer is
still the best
determinant about which cancers get
detected
but how do you know that right you have
your insurance card
they give you the slip to go to a
particular lab i mean how are you going
to know that your radiologist has looked
at dozens of mammograms and is really
the right person to diagnose your
your x-ray you wouldn't necessarily know
that however
there are some specialty centers that
are are geared towards
high-volume um situations
they are known as with the women's
imaging center and that's all they do is
mammograms they don't do
lungs and they don't do knees and backs
and so forth so
usually they're going to be the
specialty centers now there are
specialty centers right here in southern
nevada and plenty of places that also
offer 3d imaging as well
now mammograms are covered by insurance
but for
uninsured patients a mammogram typically
costs between eighty dollars and two
hundred dollars